hey guys how's it going welcome to IG
likes I'm Justine and this is the show
where I like things and you guys like
things and you send them to me and I
show them to you simple as that so my
friend welcome to the first week of
March although this week we're gonna be
covering stuff that happened last week
I'll have a few things they're happening
next week it gets a little confusing
anyway let's move on to my favorite
videos that I saw this week I'm pretty
sure everyone and their mother including
my own mother has sent me the Taylor
Swift goat videos but it's not getting a
little more crazy because there's Miley
goat there's Bieber goat most
importantly this past week one of my
favorite videos of all time was hosted
now out of every single video that's
ever been posted on the internet this is
now my new favorite video it's an insane
rope swinging jump cliff Canyon you're
gonna juice
there's amazing cinematography there's
amazing people jumping off cliffs
including an amazing person named shake
our I don't even know how your wife let
you do that none of you videos that I
came across my friend Francesca who
always does my hair she knows that I
absolutely hate to curl my hair because
I'm always so afraid that it's gonna
burn or fall off Wow this video here
this girl does burn her hair off don't
ever turn your curling irons up this
high Lisa please don't do it right here
there's a lot of you guys now I'm super
obsessed with iPhone apps and iPhones in
general
hence iJustine so I've been using this
app called vine where it kind of lets
you take super short loopable little
movies and you can share them with your
friends because that's the social
networking is all about over sharing
does that be so easy to use that it
actually disgusts me already
oh just recorded a clip just recording
out another clip just recorded another
clip and then it loops them all together
you hit next and you click done and you
just made a movie now even though this
isn't happening until next week the new
tomb raider game is coming out and I'm
actually really excited
I can remember when I was younger like
feels like forever I never really had
the original PlayStation but I used to
play tomb raider on my friends
Playstations I was always been intended
did have a say go so I don't know why I
didn't have the game himself mom why
don't you give me to him ready for
Christmas because I was the girl asking
for RAM for my computers and yeah anyway
whatever I was talking about what was I
talking about Tomb Raider I did get a
chance to meet Camilla Luddington at the
Spike something video game awards and
she was super sweet like she was so nice
I wanted to hug her I wanted to put her
in a suitcase and bring her home to my
house and we would hang out and we've
become really good friends so I think
that's that's how friendships start by
taking someone shoving them in your
suitcase and now on to beauty fashions I
don't think we established a name for
this section for the video because you
guys are well aware that I love March
and I love spring because that means
colors and nice warm weather so I put
together this cute little outfit for a
shoot that I did last week it's colorful
you can wear it to a picnic you can wear
it to up to the salad bar you can wear
it wherever
also one last thing for it when we find
it ready bow no hold on I found myself
back together
I bought this today when I went to you
my eyebrows done it is called hyper
color no brown hair powder it's by
almost anzio on a stage are honest
though I don't know so I don't know put
this on my hair yet or do i powder hair
color and the woman said all you do is
you take it and you rub it on your hair
and then I think you spray it with
hairspray and it'll give you a nice
little pop of color obviously I chose
purple wonder what my favorite color is
I'm giving you one guess what for me too
tempting to put this in my hair in an
upcoming video probably on my other I
just seen channel what do you say Oh
Wow it looks so cool thank you guys so
much for watching this episode make sure
you click like which is that little
thumbs up button down there if you
really really liked it you can even add
it to your favorites so most importantly
make sure you subscribe so you'll see in
your subscription feed when I post in a
video or maybe you won't see it ok
sometimes it doesn't always work I'll
still be able to tweet me some
suggestions for next week's IJ likes so
anything cool that happens during this
week just tweet it to me at iJustine and
use the hashtag IJ likes so I'll be a
little search for it next week when I
shoot my next episode see you tomorrow
oh wait maybe this is actually eyeshadow